Hello Pscyh 2 Goers, we just want to take the time to
thank you for all your kind support.
We are a team of dedicated, passionate
and hardworking individuals who come together everyday
with one goal in mind. We want to make psychology
come alive for you. We are self-funded
and recently launched our patron
If you enjoy the work we do and find it meaningful please stick around
till the end of the video for more information
on how to get more involved with us and all the cool rewards
you can get from us. We hope you enjoy this video!
It's actually quite to easy to tell when someone has fallen in love with you.
But due to our tendency in human history to complicate things
by overthinking, we may not believe it at first.
Thanks to hook up culture, men especially,
have a bad rep for being non committed players
But this doesn't make anyone immune to catching feelings.
Are you wondering if someone is beginning to fall for you?
Here are 6 clear signs he's in love with you.
Number 1, he enjoys poking fun at you
on a regular basis. Although teasing is a common form of flirting
in the initial stages of dating, over time
when they get to know and fall in love with you,
they start to come up with inside jokes only you understand
that makes it more exclusive and special
People in love tend to be more in tune with their playful youthfulness
It's important to be able to laugh with your partner so you can
handle all life's curveballs thrown your way
Number 2, he opens up about things that are
hard to talk about. This is especially true if
your partner is more shy or reserved. When someone
is slow to open up and selective about who he lets in,
pay attention to what he reveals to you. Does he share
embarrassing stories or things that are hard to talk about?
If he lets his guard down and shows his vulnerable side
it means you are becoming someone he can trust and depend on
Number 3, he pays attention to details about you.
It's common for people to remember things about you
when they are initially trying to impress you
But when they are in love, it goes deeper than that
People in love pay attention to the details. Big or small,
because they genuinely find you interesting and enjoy
learning everything about you. If you think your partner is
beginning to know you better than you know yourself
There's a pretty good chance he's falling for you
Number 4, he becomes more open minded
about trying the things you like
Whether it means going to a restaurant you've been dying to visit
or trying something as bold and dramatic as skydiving
People in love are willing to step out of their comfort zones
to make unique memories with you. Even if he's not always
a fan of the things he tries because of you,
just being open minded about your interests and hobbies is a clear sign
he cares enough about you to support them.
When someone is in love, the last thing they will do is be
dismissive or judgmental towards you so don't worry about embracing
your true self.
Number 5, he's protective of you and
helps you get through your bad days. It's easy to love someone at their best
but the ultimate test of love is being able to accept one another
at each other's worst.
In relationships, you are challenged to become a better person.
When someone is willing to help you get through your bad days,
not only is it a sign of maturity, but it shows
that you have a stable relationship built on trust,
compassion and understanding. If he sees the potential
in the two of you being long term,
then he will continue to work on making that happen.
Number 6,
he's at ease around you and doesn't
feel pressured to change. We are rarely ever our true selves
when we are dating someone in the first few months
It kind of feels like a prolonged interview. But when you are in love,
dating stops feeling like a performance and more like home.
You will notice that he will stop feeling self-conscious
about himself. Whether that means having bad hair in the morning
or just dancing in front of you. When the walls start coming down
that's when you know, you've truly reached his heart
Do you agree with these signs?
Please share your thoughts with us below!
Also, don't forget to subscribe
for more content from Psych2Go and check out our patron.
With your contribution, you can receive our Psy pendant,
tshirts, issues of our magazines
and many more membership benefits.
Your funding will help us produce quality script writing, voiceovers
and animations that makes our content both
entertaining and educational. Thanks for watching! :)